thank you
[Music]
leotroll derived from apricot pits has
been banned in the United States since
1963. the Food and Drug Administration
says it's harmless but also worthless in
fighting cancer its benefits if any
purely psychological but in Mexico it's
legal every one of us standing here has
somebody that we love and care for we're
not doing it for ourselves We're Going
Through Hell smuggling at across borders
bootlegging it doing things we've never
done in our lives because we love
someone so deeply that we want them to
live there are many patients in this
country for whom we know we have
effective therapies and they are
abandoning these kind of Therapies in
pursuit of
scientifically unproven methods
everybody who's looked at this problem
is to a degree affected by the fact that
it's a political as well as a scientific
issue you can't can't get away from that
when you go home to Canada where Leia
Trill is not available what will you do
[Music]
I guess I'll die if I can't get it
would you be prepared to buy illegally
obtained leotrill in order to have it I
steal it
you plan to take any Lateral with you
when you leave even though it's illegal
yes
Dr Robert good president of the phone
Kettering Institute one of the world's
biggest and richest cancer research
centers said leotroll does not prevent
cancer nor cure cancer or stop cancer
from spreading
oh
my impression of Leia troph was that
this was sort of another example of the
madness and delusion of crowds you know
that under the pressure of this terrible
disease otherwise sensible people might
become desperate and turn to something
that was patently worthless or false and
showed the gullibility of people in the
face of disaster
in the year 1977
Newsweek estimated that 70 000 Americans
went across the border to get lateral in
Mexico
seventy thousand it was a about a tenth
of the cancer population at that time
and maybe a fifth of all the people with
terminal cancer
actually making the Trek to the
different Tijuana clinics to get
leotroll and this came at a time when
the war on the official war on cancer
really was a tremendous amount of
disarray
so it was almost like the public whose
hopes had been raised for a quick cure
for cancer but in time for the
bicentennial had given up hope on the
established medicine and the established
science and had shifted their allegiance
a good portion has shifted their
allegiance to this you know
unconventional treatment and is this age
or age-old war between quackery and
conventionality if you will in medicine
and more than any other time in history
the weight of public opinion seemed to
have shifted over to this quack side and
you had something like 19 different
states had enacted legislation to
legalize layatrol this was a a big
tremendous change in the Public's
attitude
I was born in Brooklyn New York long
story short I wound up majoring in
Classics and went to Stanford University
on a National Defense Education Act
Fellowship so I spent three years plus
at Stanford in the late 60s and then
taught Classics for a while went back to
New York in the early 70s more or less
to be nearer to my family and my wife's
family
she and I have been together since we
were in high school
I was new in the school Abraham Lincoln
High School in Brighton it was between
Brighton and Coney Island
on Ocean Parkway
and I was going up the down staircase
and he was coming down the down
staircase so he stopped and said I don't
know you
well I'm new my name is Martha Buena
and I said maybe someday it'll be Moss
just like that
that made an impression on me obviously
and we've been married now almost 50
years
[Music]
being aware of current events was very
important to my parents we would sit
around and watch the news every night
and of course during the 70s the early
70s the Vietnam War was still going on
and
every night it seemed as though there
was a deep frustration with what
I'm sure many people experienced as a
sort of a sense of powerlessness and an
inability to be able to affect a change
so I wound up hearing about a job that
was opening up at Memorial Sloan
Kettering I was working at Hunter
College on 68th Street in Manhattan and
memorials on the same street and so it
was just a kind of a strafe thought that
I should go and apply for this job it
was in public relations public affairs
and the job title was science writer now
I didn't have any qualifications or
training in science writing but my basic
appeal to them was that I was a
reasonably bright and well-educated guy
I had no background in science much less
in cancer but I thought that I could see
things the way that the average
layperson would see things and ask the
questions about their research that any
outside person including let's say
potential donors would would uh ask one
interview after another after another
writing
endless samples of his work and
finally he got the job I started work on
June 3rd 1974 and it was uh tremendously
exciting time this was in some ways the
best job that I ever had certainly had
ever had up to that point and in a sense
that I ever had because it was a an
opportunity for me to quote unquote go
back to school and learn this whole
amazing world of biology and medical
science that you know I had only very
peripheral involvement with up until
that point
I remember the day my father was hired
at Sloan Kettering it was very exciting
that he got this job to fight a war that
we all could get behind the war on
cancer that was that was a war that
really felt like it was going to unite
us all and my father could put his
passion for
a social justice cause and his love for
Science and put that into something so
important
at that time
it was a very unusual moment really
because with the launching of the war on
cancer Memorial Kettering had taken a
very kind of radical turn they had
appointed a man by the name of Robert a
good Bob good to be the president of
Sloan Kettering Institute and he then
had appointed a man by the name of Lloyd
j old to be the vice president of the
Institute
[Music]
and there was another vice president
Chester stock
president of the overarching corporation
was Lewis Thomas
Dr good who was president of the
Institute and I actually were discussing
writing a book together so we had dinner
together we went out socially here I was
a 31 you know the bottom of that really
of the totem pole and I was befriended
by and friendly with the top person in
the instant very heady stuff for a young
science writer Bob good was the most I
think to this day the most published
biologist in the world ever I think uh
1200 papers
around the time that I was hired he had
this terrible thing happen one of his
young Associates William Summerlin had
claimed that he could transplant tissue
skin from one unrelated Mouse to another
unrelated Mouse and he proved this by
allegedly taking skin from a black mouse
soaking it in some special solution
transplanting it onto a white mouse and
making it stick
and they demonstrated these mice all
over the world a lab a technician at
Sloan Kettering noticed as they were
going up to make one of these
presentations he was carrying the cages
with the mice and he thought hmm those
transplants look like they're in a
slightly different place than they had
been yesterday and he went back to the
lab he took some alcohol rubbed on the
transplants and off they came there was
the white mouse underneath a renowned
Research Hospital the Memorial Sloan
Kettering Cancer Center in New York said
today one of its scientists has admitted
he put out phony research results he's
Dr William Summerlin 35 an expert in
Immunology a Review Committee said
Summerlin painted dark patches on the
skin of two white mice so it appeared he
had successfully transplanted skin
between animals genetically incompatible
and this Summerlin had had the audacity
to actually paint these black splotches
onto these white ice with a magic magic
marker I mean talk about nerve you know
and here good had co-authored these
papers good had promoted him literally
promoted him to be a full member of The
Institute which is like full professor
and the whole thing blew up in his face
I mean overall ironies of ironies I
walked in on this very flawed very
crisis-ridden institution the day that I
found out I was going to get the job I
was riding home I lived in Brooklyn and
I was riding home on the subway and I
glanced over the shoulder of one of the
other strap hangers on the subway and I
see Mouse Scandal rocks Sloan headering
and I thought oh no you know my luck
I just hired on you know as as the third
mate on the Titanic
that's how things started for me and
kind of went downhill from there
on the very first day of my job in in
public affairs I was handed a big
portfolio of uh letters from the public
this was part of the uh sort of The
Unwanted part of the job that no you
know nobody else wanted to do and there
were kinds of
strange letters from the public like one
I remember one woman who insisted that
the cure for cancer was water that had
drained or run underneath um pine trees
in Maine and if you recovered that water
that would cure cancer and there were
many other you know folk remedies and so
forth the people were proposing to us as
part of their contribution to the war on
cancer but the at least half of the
letters had to do with a substance
called leotroll or amygdalin and they
were often in the form of complaints why
we weren't examining this or what do you
think of this or why sometimes why are
you covering this up and of course this
wasn't the part of the job that I was
most looking forward to but it was part
of my responsibility to answer these
letters the trial is labeled Mandela in
the trial glucoside
and the enzyme it breaks this up is the
beta glucosidase and then hydrocyanic
acid is liberated and it comes down here
and hits the tumor and kills the tumor
because there's plenty of beta
glucosides in the tumor put that by
Nature
then that's the end of the tumor then
the cyanide sugar molecule releases
cyanide gas since cyanide is a deadly
poison why doesn't the cyanide kill the
patient if any of the cyanide gets out
in normal tissues well then you have the
enzyme rudinase which changes the
cyanide into thiocyanate and is excreted
into the urine in therefore there's no
toxicity from the lateral treatment
we had a um a form letter that had been
drawn up before I got there about leotro
and it was fairly neutral and it just
basically said we're investigating this
and
um when we have results we'll announce
them to the public there was nothing
particularly negative or positive in the
letter and I would send that out to the
person who is communicating with us and
be done with it
I went up to the Walker laboratory in
Rye New York which was then a division
of Sloan Kettering I went up for a
different purpose to interview a
different scientist but I had lunch with
Dr Chester stock who was the vice
president of Sloan Kettering in charge
of the worker lab and Dr kanumatsu
sugiora Who was this 80-something
scientist at slum Kettering and was kind
of an oddity in the sense that he was I
think the oldest working scientist in
The Institute maybe the maybe second
oldest person in the entire Center out
of 4 600 employees
and so we had a nice lunch and Dr stock
on the way back uh to to New York City
agreed with me or maybe suggested to me
that I should write a little
biographical article about Dr sigoura
and his distinguished uh 60-year career
uh in cancer research
I like that idea I kind of liked Dr
siguri was sort of a grandfatherly
figure and so I made the appointment and
I went back to interview him and then in
the course of that interview
towards the end I asked him what he was
currently investigating because I knew
he he was there the whole day I mean he
came in early in the morning and stayed
the whole day to do research and he said
with his thick Japanese accent I'm
studying amygdalin and it took me a
minute to sort of decipher that
amygdalin that was the same substance as
the layotrol you know the quack remedy
that I was writing to people about back
in my uh in my office
and I said to him
well what is there to investigate if it
doesn't work this is my my firm
conviction and he he got up and he took
down he had a uniform series of lab
books and he took it opened it up and he
showed me that when he gave the uh
leotroller amygdalin
um that the tumors would stop growing
for a number of weeks after a while
they'd start growing again
um so I was being very uh very young and
inexperienced you know I was quite
amazed at this and
he said but that's really not the
important thing the important thing is
this and he showed me the the lab books
and you could see clearly that um in
about
um 80 to 90 percent of the animals that
only got saline solution salt water
solution which is an inert substance
that there was um metastases or
secondary growths in the lungs of these
animals and in the lateral treated
animals only uh between 10 and 20
percent had metastases and segurin is
very characteristic low-key way said
well it would be very interesting if it
prevented it completely it was a little
disappointed that it hadn't completely
prevented the occurrence of lung
metastases he said but lateral it's not
a cure for cancer it is a good
palliative drug based upon of course
only on his laboratory experiments I he
didn't he didn't know about to my
knowledge didn't know about or care
about what was going on in Mexico it was
very vaguely aware of anything outside
the lab I would say it was hard to do
disbelieve him in any sense because he
had no ax to grind he would sometimes
tell me for hours what his day was like
on and on describing his impressions of
kanamatsu sugiora and tsugiora had told
him that lateral worked
that it stopped metastases in 80 percent
of the mice
and it could be should be tested further
to see if this is a useful drug for
human beings
that's all you know so uh I came away
quite quite astonished really when
running back to my office and told my
boss Jerry Delaney about this and Jerry
who probably knew more about the
situation than I uh than I realized
um told me something very unusual at
that point I mean very strange in a way
he said I want you to befriend Dr
sugiora and and be aware of exactly
what's happening with his work because I
need to know as public as head of public
affairs public relations what is going
on up there because this thing could
blow up and Blindside us and you know it
was a it was a fairly reasonable request
I think for a PR director and I had sort
of an entree now with Dr segurus I don't
want to say I was a spy but you know it
was it was a sincere interest on my part
it also was sanctioned by my boss to to
do this so over the next
few years really you know I became close
to Dr Segura
[Music]
one took place in the 74 and the other
took place in 75. the Sloan Kettering
especially in the first meeting pleaded
with the assembled powers that be in the
medical field that's to say the FDA the
National Cancer Institute the NIH and
the American Cancer Society so they
pleaded with them to allow them to do
human clinical trials they presented in
a very fair way the Leia troll data that
had been accumulated to that point July
2nd 1974
you had the top leaders of memorials on
Kettering go down from New York down to
Washington for this meeting and then you
had from the NCI you had four of the top
figures and from FDA you had about a
dozen people it's unprecedented unheard
of so here you had Lewis Thomas never
really friendly towards leotro never
said a good word really but he was there
Bob good who vacillated Chester stock
who I think believed in segura's results
and Lloyd old who really was the driving
force and who co-chaired the meeting
what a funny statement is Dr old has
written to several World users of Leia
troll he found two groups one those who
used it and found it a value and two
those who had not used it and did not
believe in it
he feels that amygdalin is as non-toxic
as glucose
and then he summarized cigaroo's results
phone Kettering tested tumor-bearing
animals 100 treated with amygdalin 25
showed lung metastases to 100 not
treated with amygdalene 75 showed lung
matasty he flipped the numbers by using
the amygdalan
some Kettering group believes their
results show that amygdalin used in
animals with tumors shows a decrease in
lung metastases slower tumor growth and
pain relief
and Dr Stock thinks studies on amygdalin
should be made particularly regarding
pain relief and reduction of lung
metastases
that's the message that Lewis Thomas Bob
good Lloyd old and Justice stock went to
Washington to deliver to the FDA oh
[Music]
here's a letter from The Office of the
President and director of Sloan
Kettering Institute dated January 24
1975 to Dr Mario Soto de Leon platoon
has something it's not the Magic Bullet
but it has helped a lot of patients that
were already sent home today and it's
from Lloyd old vice president and
associate director of Sloan Kettering it
says Dear Dr Soto it was indeed a
pleasure to have you and Dr sannin visit
our Institute and share with us your
clinical experience with amygdalin in
cancer patients I was pleased to hear
from Dr Shannon that our proposed
collaborative controlled trials have the
approval of your hospital we are looking
forward to a fruitful exchange of
information my best wishes sincerely
yours Lloyd j old so this shows you I
mean beyond the shadow of a doubt that
the Sloan Kettering leadership was
actually trying to set up its own
clinical trial in Mexico
they're excited about it the results are
coming out positive they like some
aspects of the theory behind it they
think they might be able to produce
drugs along the lines of cyanide release
that are even better than leotro and the
bottom line was you know we think that
we should do clinical trials
um the next year they went back to the
second meeting March 4th 1975. now this
is at the NCI this was a higher level
meeting we've got Frank rousher who is
the director of NCI and a lot of other
very very famous figures from the NCI in
those days this is a who's who of the
NCI and from memorial stone Kettering
we've got old Thomas stock and then
right below Dan Martin from Catholic
Medical Center and people from the
American Cancer site now what had
happened is that Dan Martin Daniel S
Martin from the Catholic Medical Center
in Queens had joined the discussion and
he had been the person who created I
guess he'd say the cd8 F1 Mouse which
was the main animal model that Segura
had used and he had become
an adamant opponent of leotrove because
of his belligerent personality Dr Dan
Martin's career was at a dead end he had
lost a big lawsuit against his own
institution and had been relegated to an
abandoned and graffiti-covered Hulk of a
building in Queens the National Cancer
Institute had abruptly turned down all
of his Grant requests he had no
customers for his cd8 F1 mice
then in mid 1975 NCI suddenly gave him a
million dollars four million today
to breed mice quote to see whether
segura's initial findings at Sloan
Kettering might not have been right
so Martin exploded from his utter
isolation in an obscure Corner onto the
national Limelight as a supposed expert
on layatrol boring the country
speechifying writing op-eds shouting
that lateral was worthless and dangerous
I think it is more than coincidental
that Martin launched this hate campaign
at the very moment that NCI gave him a
grant of one million dollars
take a position against quackery I think
is very self-justifying on the part of
some people within the medical community
it makes them feel better about
themselves and about their profession
and it's also a quick road to a success
because everybody you know in the
establishment likes the the night on the
White Horse who's going to come and save
the world from the danger of quackery so
it was seen as a within their circles as
a popular thing to do
foreign
[Music]
ly the statements that they that they
were making each of the top leaders not
not old but good
Thomas and stock became increasingly
Negative they ranged from
misrepresentations to what I would say
were egregious lies and it built over
time in seventy in the beginning of 75
and it built and built each one seemed
to get emboldened by the other one to
make a more definitively anti-layageal
statement which was odd because nothing
was happening
at that point scientifically to trigger
those comments very distressing very
distressing it culminated with a
statement that Chester stock gave to
David Leff of medical world news in 75
saying we have found lateral negative in
all the animal systems that we have
tested
so I think it was that point at which it
crystallized in my mind that this was a
cover-up to say we have not a scintilla
of evidence or not a shred of evidence
showing that late draws any effective in
any animal system period which is the
kind of thing the statement they were
making that's a lie
quite pure and simple a lie
I had sort of set myself a goal of
talking to about leotroll to all the top
administrators in the center
this was part of my sort of my checklist
and my message essentially was we've got
to publish the guru's results with
lateral
an old's response was different than any
of the other leaders at the center
he did something and said something that
I will never forget
he got up from his chair when I when I
said obviously he's got it from his
chair and he and he he said to me now he
said do you want to know where we get
all of our new ideas well now you have
to understand here's the vice president
of Sloan Kettering Institute talking to
you know a fledgling science writer said
well of course you know and he kind of
tiptoed behind me behind the couch and
went over to his bookshelf and took down
a book and came back and he said here
this is the Bible
I took a look at this it was the
American Cancer society's book unproven
methods of cancer management
I had this book it was the quack list we
were supposed to refer to this book so
we'd know what was quackery and what was
authentic science
I mean this was the most you know really
scientifically speaking the most
mind-blowing moment of my life because
here's the vice president to sell
Kettering telling me that The Source the
basic source with new ideas within
Orthodox science came from what is
regarded generally as quackery
I mean
it was hard to comprehend and I've told
this story to people sometimes and you
know they think I'm exaggerating and
maybe making this up but no I I wasn't
as I said I had a little checklist of
who to talk to about this sort of the
Let My People Go moment and I went to
good and I got nothing but BS from him
in other words just the party line he
wasn't going to open up to me much less
say we get all our new ideas from the
quack list I mean you know we were
worlds away from that good was a
politician he was always known as a as a
politician we called him a political
scientist you know all he said to me was
I'm just like you
I said really he said yes you can be
fired and I can be fired too
and with stock
I mean I confronted stock
and absolutely put it in his face that
that what he was saying wasn't true and
he basically I mean his initial and I
think most telling response was just go
ahead and say it anyway that's when I
lost all respect for him because I saw
that he you know he was playing the game
uh whatever the pressure was he was
going to play the game and I don't think
he had very many personal regrets and
Thomas wouldn't talk to me
very difficult
and in night after night he would come
home and
and we were very upset because
because he was upset
there was a lot of anxiety
over
whether or not to
act on his conscience
and put
the ability to provide for his family at
risk
or whether to just keep his mouth shut
and go along and you know maintain the
status quo and do what they wanted him
to do which was essentially to lie
I was I was really scared I mean I was
scared in a lot of levels
um
younger than them totally you know
nowhere near them in terms of knowledge
um trying arguing the case for testing
the most quackish of all the quack
remedies telling them essentially that
they were doing something wrong I mean
it was a textbook case of what not to do
if you intend to uh pursue a career at a
at an institution like that here
everything was going great for me I said
you know you're not the man that that
you know that they want there if they
want somebody who's going to lie that's
not you
you're not the one who's going to be
doing that what do you do you've got the
best job you've ever had and who may
ever have in your life and uh your boss
is telling you to lie so I didn't know
how to respond to this it really was a
classic
case of where your your conscience is
you know is strained uh and my response
was to leak the documents I wanted to
have my cake and to eat it as well I
wanted my job and I also wanted to have
a clear conscience
so I guess this is why people leak
documents all the time this took a lot
of doing to convince Segura to give me
the actual photocopies of his lab notes
I mean that was really sticking my neck
out because what if you know they asked
him and on my birthday in 75 he gave
them to me
he gave me all his his internal memos
and his lab notes March 1st 1974 table 2
shows that repeated injections of a
thousand milligrams per kilogram per day
of amygdalin for 2 to 15 weeks failed to
destroy the spontaneous cancer in mice
however it caused an inhibition in about
50 percent of the tumors it also shows
amygdalin or lateral had a strong
inhibitory effect on the development of
new tumors and on lung metastases 11
percent in the lateral treated animals
against 89 percent in the control of
animals in mice the General Health and
appearance of the amygdalan-treated
animals with tumors was much better than
that of the controls panamatsu sugiora
March 1st 1974 May 31st
1974 which incidentally was three days
before I actually was started my work at
Sloan Kettering Segura wrote the table
results showed repeated injections of 2
000 milligrams per kilogram per day of
amygdalin for in four to nine weeks had
a strong inhibitory effect on the
development of lung metastases the
detailed data it's it's overwhelming and
even the size of the lung metastases
that we're seeing is noted for each
animal every animal in every one of
segura's experiments is accounted for
how many injections what the duration of
the experiment was the growth of the
tumor the final size of the tumor the
number of lung metastases and
determination of the experiment one of
the most interesting things they did and
very clever thing was to try to see if
they could prevent cancer with layotrol
the present study shows that for the
first three quarters of their lifespan
21 months the day we prolonged
injections of amygdalin did not prevent
the development of mammary cancer in
mice completely however it had a
definite reduction and in development of
mammary tumors 70 percent in the
controls against 48 percent in the
amygdal untreated mice it also shows the
Midland had a strong inhibitory effect
on the development of lung metastases in
mice 75 inhibition against 22 percent in
controls
and again tremendous detail here's his
report on a different system the Swiss
albino mice spontaneous tumors in
retired breeder mice the megalon had a
strong inhibitory effect on the
development of lung metastases in mice
77 percent inhibition against seven
percent inhibition in controls 77 versus
seven the General Health and appearance
of the amygdal entreated animals were
much better and that of the controls
resulted paying with mammary tumors
occurring in swissobynomites are
essentially the same as those obtained
with mammary tumors occurring in cd8f1
mice cyan kanamasu sugiora February 8
1975.
and again every Mouse detailed notes
[Music]
the first person that I took this to was
Jane Brody at the New York Times who was
the health editor and then I waited and
waited and she finally came down and
interviewed everybody uh the people she
wanted to see she gave them a checklist
I was in my boss's office when he was
talking to her about it so I heard
second hand is it where she didn't ask
to speak to Segura
so I felt terribly disappointed and she
wrote a very negative story
couldn't believe that positive data that
I had presented her with had turned into
kind of a typical anti-layer story on
the front page of the times
it was a devastating uh blow because I
think also I realized
I can't so easily convince the
mainstream
about this so now I had by one route you
know the sort of the media route was
more or less cut off from me at least
momentarily then I decided in the middle
of the summer of 75 uh I had to sort of
go whole hog and I packaged up a copy
and sent it off to the committee for a
freedom of choice in medicine which was
the main pro-laitral lobbying group that
did sort of propaganda for freedom of
choice which was the rubric under which
leicho was being promoted cancer patient
Steve gatler claiming he was cured by
Leia Trail said the issue boils down to
Freedom of Choice his right to use the
processed extract of apricot pits over
conventional therapies I plead with FDA
foreign
to choose our own therapy why should I
an American citizen
have to go in a black market or smuggle
something that I should have the freedom
to choose and the committee for freedom
of choice of course ran with it this was
their dream come true and they
republished the data
the lateral movement was really in some
sense as an offshoot of the John Birch
Society and this is like an extreme
right-wing group to the right of what
you know what we would Now call the tea
party I mean get the us out of the U.N
and you know all kinds of conspiracy
Eisenhower is a communist and all this
kind of extreme extreme right-wing stuff
and I didn't want to have anything to do
with that and I was looking for sort of
to counteract or count to balance that
because everything that was coming out
about Leia troll was sort of Tainted uh
by its association with the Birch
Society most of the people you read
about uh in the lateral movement were
either in the Birch Society or
affiliated with it or sympathetic to it
I wasn't and coming from out of the
Vietnam anti-vietnam War movement you
know and even going back before that I
mean my orientation was more left left
of center
and so there was this group called
science for the people
I had no particular interest in science
with people but it seemed like a kind of
a an organizational format that I could
use to maybe sort of Interest the left
in this this is a group that was active
in the early to mid 70s which was sort
of a leftist progressive organization
that was involved in a lot of scientific
issues and I realized I found out that
Ralph was doing something other on
cancer treatment and controversies
involving cancer and I figured well let
me start work with Ralph and see what if
we have anything in common I started to
get into it more and more and I realized
that a lot of the work he was doing
wasn't just on controversies of cancer
research but also the interplay between
big business and big cancer essentially
and the pharmaceutical industry the
corporate industry the scientific
controversies all sort of overlapped in
fact they still overlap anybody who sees
some of the things going on today
realize that these issues in one way or
another were still with us and he became
sort of convinced by my arguments about
leotroll although the majority was very
skeptical and I think if it you know I
mean the the double whammy was quack
cancer remedy and John Birch Society it
seemed like you know the like the
perfect poison the last thing in the
world that a group like that would be
ever be sympathetic or to or interested
in it was becoming very very difficult
and then I said look we have to do
something you know maybe you're not
ready to
go out and you know ferment to ride in
the streets over this but we have to do
something
and because the people within the New
York chapter of science so the people
wouldn't go any further with this we
broke away that committee and formed our
own organization called second opinion
of course a second opinion is when you
get a first opinion such as the person
has cancer and you want to find out if
another expert would have a different uh
take on that we called our newsletter
second opinion because we felt that
people were getting the first opinion
from Memorial Sloan Kettering but we had
another
diagnosis of the problem as it were we
had another take on what really was
going on the second opinion was largely
Anonymous it was really written by and
put and put out by laid out by Sloan
Kettering employees a lot of them were
people with grievances of various kinds
about their treatment on the job and so
forth so it became kind of a anonymous
a way for people to Voice or air their
discontents in a you know large Center 4
600 employees there's always going to be
things happening that people are not
happy with especially the testing of
leotro at Sloan Kettering
so we started working and we had a small
group and it turned out that just out of
coincidence I was the only one who had
no collect connection to Stone Kettering
everybody else was either at Sloan
Kettering or could be identified this is
not an academic institution so you had
no protection of your freedom of speech
you would have been fired if if you had
Associated yourself publicly so but I
had no connection whatsoever I was at
City University of New York at the time
and and so in fact I became sort of the
spokesperson for the group The the
outside agitator who was coming in and
uh and and being the face of the group
because no one else could at the time
even though they were doing all the work
you know Ralph well had all the inside
information and as you recruited more
people and we recruited them from inside
Sloan Kettering and Affiliated
institutions and it was all like
literally cut and pasted when my wife
had some background in graphics so she
cut and pasted the issue together and we
had it mimeographed and stapled and we
handed it out at Memorial
and there was a lot of interest in this
and so as people came into the
organization then they brought their own
concerns and some of those concerns were
labor concerns we became like the outlet
the Clearinghouse for a lot of
grievances within the institution of
firing that some people thought was
racist in nature at least the person who
got fired did we had some patient
complaints we had complaints coming from
the Department of Nursing about the
chairman of Nursing and a group and more
and more people came in to the group so
at one point we had about 20 people I
think you know in and at meetings and so
forth
kind of then wrote These articles about
leotroll so the second opinion for a few
years became enormously popular to the
point where we were printing 5 000
copies of each issue and
we distributed them within hours there
were only 4 600 employees at the center
we would just stand there and we didn't
have to Hawk it we didn't have to hand
it to people they came racing over to us
on their way into work people would take
the the workers would always take it the
nurses would usually take it the
low-level administrators didn't want to
be seen touching it but the high level
administrators they all wanted to see
every single thing that was in it and
Ralph used to describe how when it came
out every high level administrator was
sitting at his desk and nothing would
get done in the hospital until they
would read through every single line of
the paper to see what Scandal was going
to come out what controversy was going
to come out whose names are going to be
named and and what they had to do about
it and they of course provoked an uproar
immediately do you know anything
everybody was asked do you know anything
no no no this was so 60-ish and here we
were now in 1975 76 but you know the 60s
kind of lingered this was the era Nixon
had just been kicked out of office and
at the moment you know it was kind of it
seemed like the right thing the right
way to do things
in the pre-internet era we were trying
to give the average person or the person
without uh specialized medical training
some insight into what was going on
within one institution
uh where evidence was accumulating of
the effectiveness of a treatment but the
top Administration felt that it was
perfectly okay to give people any BS
that they wanted because nobody would
ever have a way of knowing that what
they said wasn't true and they didn't
count on the fact that you know there
were a few people inside who were not
going to stand for that and I think that
sort of upset their plans
[Music]
it started out just with Segura running
the experiment and coming up with uh you
know very positive results every
experiment that was done that came out
positive had to be redone and retested
and rechecked because every time it was
something positive that couldn't be
accepted I mean that's science
it's it was a predetermined uh
conclusion
then they held their famous June 15
1977 press conference at Memorial about
100 reporters and all the the major
media were there the press conference
was one of the strangest events I've
ever been in in my life I helped to
organize it I wrote the press release
for it laboratory mice at the Sloan
Kettering Institute one of the world's
biggest and richest cancer research
centers have been tested with Leia Trill
for four years today Stone Kettering
announced the result there they all were
all the the top people Chester stock our
summary statement is we do not have
evidence supporting taking amygdalin to
clinical trial
Bob good we tried to find out from
scientific information available whether
there was any real scientific evidence
that the drug amygdalin or the so-called
late Trail had any effect on on cancer
in any form and there was no such
scientific evidence and Louis Thomas
there is no evidence in the several
animal models that have been studied
that led for a little bit for amygdalene
possesses any biological activity with
respect to cancer one way or the other
Lloyd ran away
I mean at the time I wasn't thrilled
with that the day of the the Fateful
press conference in 1977 they announced
that Lloyd was in Tahiti or someplace
seguru was there and it was quite a hot
you know High Point really a incredible
tension word had leaked out that Sloan
Kettering had some positive results was
that this was the final nail in the
coffin Elantra
do you agree with the conclusions in the
summary statement
conclusion
the fact is not either Pure or prevent
cancer
I I agree of course Marisa don't agree
but I I agree what our Institute said
why
well I don't know why but uh
I think a good can you stick by your
results
yes I stick
I I hope that somebody able to confirm
my result later on
it was just this electrifying moment I
mean you can't even
imagine you know the whole I mean my
maybe this was just my emotion I felt
such a a surge of
um
admiration
for him and and it was so it was such a
poignant moment man was about I don't
know 87 or 89 years old and here his
whole career was on the line and and he
was magnificent and he didn't care I
mean he was not a proponent of laotra he
didn't care one way or the other as far
as that goes
I'm here almost 60 years
nobody
disputed my work every paper I sent to
the publication or always accepted
one of these results
also accepted by the publication
Sloan Kettering did something incredibly
clever in this they took his data and
they embedded it into his into the
negative paper
it's diabolical because this is how they
got him to put his name on the paper in
other words they said look you know
we're going to have an overall negative
conclusion on this but to represent your
position and your point of view we'll
put your data into the paper
and then the world can always see that
you had gotten these results we don't
agree with them but at least they're
there and this was the this was the
the compromise in a way that he made uh
in order because he told me I mean he
felt like it was more important that
somewhere someday somebody could unearth
this
study and reconstruct it from the paper
that was eventually published in the
Journal of Surgical Oncology
the scientific papers defining the that
are to be published defining this uh
this work are available to you I
understand and uh it is our
interpretation from the all of the
evidence taken together uh that there is
no substantial evidence of effectiveness
of uh amygdalin uh or laid Trill in any
form of experimental cancer study these
were sent to the Journal of Surgical
Oncology and have been accepted for
publication probably at the beginning of
1978. that's one reason we're having the
press conference today to let you know
the results in advance
there was the paper and then there was
the sort of executive summary of the
paper with all the negative conclusions
the cover document and the cover-up
document I wrote that yeah I got to
write the fake summary of the data for
Sloan Kettering and then we had the
paper the one that Segura counted on
everybody reading in order to extract
the positive data Jerry Delaney told me
take all those papers and put them
behind the curtain in the other room and
don't tell anybody they're there and so
when you walked in you got the summary
the the the the the jinned up summary of
the supposedly negative results on the
table the the the the two or three page
summary and the extensive paper preprint
of the article from Journal Surgical
Oncology hidden behind a curtain in the
adjoining room
only give it to people who specifically
ask for it it was interesting
I don't imagine our scientific
publication will have any impact on the
public
I don't think they pay too much
attention to Scientific Publications
it's interesting you know I was learning
I was still learning about the field of
of scientific journalism and journalism
in general everybody more or less 99 out
of 100 were willing to take some
catering's word for it if you said that
you know uh uh the Moon is green then
they would accept that the Moon is green
they said so and they are the experts
they should know as I say doctor
Segura first obtained an experiment
started September of 1972 the result
that caused us to do all the further
experimentation
and in that experiment he essentially
found that
the treated animals showed about 20
percent with lung metastases and the
uh control showed about 80 percent of
the animals with lung metastases
this was followed up by five additional
therapy experiments in which he
obtained
practically identical results as far as
the lung metastases are concerned
normal scientific caution at that point
we were quite interested in what he'd
found normal scientific question would
suggests that we get that confirmed
which we attempted to do
and I think our normal scientific
question was reinforced by all the
controversies surrounding the material
we then asked Dr Martin who
who had been providing all these cd8 F1
mice
to
try to confirm the results the first
experiment actually was a Cooperative
experiment in which we were trying a
special study
and then Dan Martin who was the person
who kind of invented the cd8 F1 mouse
got involved in the scene and they
started to do some experiments but in
the the sort of the classic situation
and I was
mostly involved with in sense of being a
segurus confidant on this situation was
where
they had Martin was to held the key as
to which were the treated and the
untreated animals Segura who was the
blinded person in this environment he's
the one who didn't know which were the
treated and which were the untreated he
said I know which are the treated
animals
lateral animals were had nice glossy
coats they looked good
they were healthy and the other mice
were dropping dead I said Dr Segura
please don't
tell anybody this don't tell them this
oh no but I will tell them because it's
the truth and I know which are the
treated animals and I'm going to tell Dr
Stock and I said please Dr Sarah this is
not wise it's not you shouldn't do this
because I saw that you know the writing
on the wall
the mice appear to look better
mice you know I bet Shake on the very
weak but after injection of amigatory
in the afternoon you become active
and the minute that he told them these
are the treated animals they declared
the test invalid
they declared the blindness aspect was
God I love that phrase so then the
solution to that was mix them up and
then of course he saw that tumors were
stopping stop growing in the saline
treated animals so there was something
really screwy because it looked like the
somehow the control animals were
receiving uh lay a troll one thing about
dialect Dimension here in the Russian
experiment what we did on October 1976
called branches uh
funny funny thing happened that
she we inject a military into the animal
a small human stopped to grow
for one week or five weeks she and in
the last experiment what happened is
in the control group
had to hold you two percent you must
stop the growth for one week to five
weeks were experimental
only 27 percent now we people in
chemotherapy we use a certain solution
for control of the other drugs because
it had no inhibitory effect on tumor now
this thing would happen so at something
very precuriously
foreign
if the facts are mutable based upon the
needs of the moment then science is dead
you might as well pack up and and give
it up because there's not really going
to be any honest reporting of what you
know experimentation shows so he was
fighting for I think a bigger thing
which is something he had given his
whole life
for which is
that by doing experiments and then
reporting them accurately and honestly
you advance human knowledge and
therefore you advance
the welfare
of society doctor are you then not
convinced that you're finding may very
well be confirmed in some future day yes
I'm hoping that somebody able to confirm
oh
the reason that they rushed to have a
press conference in June was because
Senator Kennedy was going to hold his
hearings on the Banning of leotro in
July of 77. and Louis Thomas was
scheduled to testify and so they needed
to come up with a countervailing paper
that would summarize and refute sugura's
positive data they were terrified of the
pro-laitral people coming into that
meeting waving the anatomy of a cover-up
with all the raw data from Sloan
Kettering showing the stoppage of
metastases and the stoppages smaller
tumors because of course that would have
left Thomas in a untenable position
essentially Thomas would have at that
point had to admit that indeed Sloan
Kettering had had four years of positive
testing with layatrol the final
conclusion uh uh on part of of of of the
people in charge of these studies and
certainly it was my final conclusion on
reviewing the data uh when when it was
pulled together for publication was that
lateral is without any effect at all
it seemed almost you know diabolical
because we couldn't believe that people
would actually do this and lie about a
promising treatment for cancer
I had been the Principal author of the
second opinion a special report at letra
and Sloan Kettering I had spent the
summer of 77 mostly researching this
paper and I had found a number of very
significant inaccuracies and we've sort
of bundled this up with a cover letter
and sent it off to a bunch of media and
to all the trustees of the institution
and to a lot of interested parties in
the cancer field and we basically said
You know here is a critique of Islam
kettering's two papers on Leia troll
then we decided to hold a press
conference of our own at the New York
Hilton
Alec was going to speak
and then I was in the office under my
Sloan Kettering
hat as it were
when the call started coming in from
reporters to ask for a comment or
clarification on what the second opinion
report was is there any validity to it
at all and so forth and Jerry would say
um well you know
there's no names of anybody employed at
Sloan Kettering on this
they claim to be a group that represents
long-tering employees but the only name
we see is Alec persnicki and we've
checked the records and Alex krishnicki
doesn't work here we have no idea who he
is we have no reason to believe that
anybody inside Sloan Kettering has
anything to do with this report somebody
had to get up from some Kettering to own
the report or else this would have had
no impact at all so I was still debating
this point and into the early evening
my son Ben
who was 10 years old said to me
I said dad you can't work for them and
against them forever it's just
impossible
and I was like sort of devastated by
this you know wisdom coming out of the
mouth of a of a 10 year old
Jerry my boss had told me to go to the
press conference
undercover for the public affairs
department at Sloan Kettering and spy on
the conference to see who was going to
show up in the meanwhile I felt Duty
bound to call him and I called him and I
said to him Jerry I can't go to the
press conference for Sloan Kettering
tomorrow because I'm going to the press
conference and I'm speaking at the press
conference and it was this dead silence
and for about 30 seconds and he said
I'll get back to you
so he hung off and now the die was cast
Okay we decided that's it you know press
conference is it's going to be out there
you're going to tell the truth get the
reporters to come get the get the papers
to come journalists and the world will
hopefully learn the truth and maybe this
will matter
I said exactly the same thing I'm saying
now I just told this chronology of what
the experiments were and tried to
accurately reflect what the pluses and
minuses what negative experiments had
been done and how it came to be that
this was interpreted
the scientists involved had made what
you could generously call errors in the
report the most glaring error was they
said that all of the chemotherapy is
currently in use against human breast
cancer could cure or cause objective
anti-cancer effects in the mouth and a
literature could not cause any
anti-cancer effects in the
so therefore lateral was obviously much
worse than standard chemotherapy this
was a an out and out lie it was it could
not have been a mistake because the man
who wrote the statement himself proved
that no known to love could cure or even
partially relieved cancer in this Mass
their own papers who the chemotherapy
didn't work in this system there's two
implications to this this later did
indeed have the effects in life then
lateral is in fact better than all of a
known as the Cancer drugs another
implication is that since known drugs
were known to cure tumors in this mouse
and then they went ahead and tested
layotroph in this same system
it seems pretty obvious that they
expected later took a sale in this
system
didn't fail we're told there were 20
positive experiments with Lance or guns
at Stone Kettering between 1972 and
1977. Military alone never cured any
cancers in life as long Kettering
Miracles had certain positive effects in
stopping the spread of the camp
said it was the best effects he had seen
in 60 years
because everybody wanted to know about
the motivation of the people involved
was there conspiracy and so on and so
forth and I I answered this as best as I
could
the Monday came and I had to go into
work which was very strange you know
because I didn't know if I had a job or
not and I somehow had convinced myself
that nothing bad was going to happen and
that they wouldn't dare fire me for
telling the truth and so this was sort
of my
you know my kindergarten thinking that
you know when you tell the truth
everything's going to be okay because
it's the truth and the truth shall set
you free will set me free all right Set
Me Free from my job
so I went in to Jerry's office and it
was very solemn
and suddenly you know he said you're
fired and we're relieving you your
employment and he gave me the the
official statement to read and the
official statement was part of which was
reprinted in the times a few days later
was that I was being fired because of as
a member of second opinion I had engaged
in activities that were harmful to the
institution and that I had failed to
carry out my most basic job
responsibilities
which I took to mean refused to lie on
behalf of my employer and so in that
sense I guess they were right I I if
that was my most basic job
responsibility I did refuse to do that I
uh burst out crying when he told me this
it just I mean it was a highly emotional
moment and also seemed so unfair it
seemed wrong I mean in an institution
that was devoted to
ostensibly to seeking scientific Truth
uh there was something terribly uh
unfair about it and that's what I had
been trying to find and to inculcate in
that whole situation was fairness
fairness towards your fairness towards
leotro fairness in the evaluation of a
set of data and boy were they not into
fairness They seized my filing cabinet
and they put it under lock and key they
had a big padlock they took it
downstairs they had these two Burly
guards come armed guards and they told
me never to enter the building again
I think it was just a liberating feeling
the lid finally blew and that's a
tremendous relief I don't know the kids
were had an emotional time you know
crying a lot you know upset kids do not
like any kind of instability and I was
trying to you know give him the greatest
support I could to to let him know that
he did the right thing this is it this
is wonderful I'm so proud of you you
have you know the a great character and
I'm just proud to be your wife
the week of the second opinion report on
lateral came out Alec and I received a
letter from Segura we had sent him a
copy and basically it said your report
is very well done and accurate please
accept my sincere congratulations and
nothing could have meant more to me than
to get that later because then I knew
that I had accomplished my main
objective which was to save this honest
work
of this honest man from destruction and
from obscurity that at least it would go
on record that the true story had been
told
foreign
even to this day what frightens people
in The Establishment about Leia troll
isn't about it has nothing to do really
with an apricot kernel extract it's
about the loss of control the loss of
authority the American oncologists in
particular are locked into a mindset
that's determined by big Pharma and
that's why they're there to hear what
the latest protocol is from bigfo
ultimately from Big Pharma and there's a
million reasons for that but that's
essentially the way you know the way the
system works so the things that don't
fit in don't nobody's interested in and
you know people who feel that they need
to come up with conspiracy theories to
explain the neglect of complementary
Medicine of the less you know the more
natural products they don't understand
the way the system works in the case of
layotrol though I think Leia Trill
became a major pain in the butt for the
medical establishment and therefore it
was targeted for Destruction the only
way I can put it
foreign
[Music]
ER was invited back to Sloan Kettering
to receive the grand rounds which is a
something that they only really do for
honored dignitaries who are visiting
maybe uh you know oncologists from
another country heads of departments
from other countries that type of thing
this was sort of part of my own personal
healing process of vis-a-vis Memorial to
be kicked out I mean by armed guards and
ordered never to set foot in the place
again to being invited back as an
honored guest 20 years 20 odd years
later uh it was you know quite a
transition I mean they never came out
formally and apologized to me for firing
me but this is I figured this is as
close to an apologies I'm ever going to
get and
as I'm mounting the podium my good
friend Bill Fair
Whispers to me don't say anything about
leotroll
[Music]
foreign
they should for their own good they
should come clean
about this because it's you know you
can't live a lie whether you're an
individual you know or an institution
that lie will will weigh you down
it's tragic and you know they they
should re-examine this I think just for
their own good
um I don't think that's I doubt if
that's going to happen but in any case
you know it's a sad very sad thing
because you know the things that you do
have repercussions to them and they did
something terrible
uh coming out of the best of motives
they weren't able to follow through on
they didn't have the courage or their
convictions put it very very mildly
they didn't have the courage of their
convictions and that's bad because then
you've gotten yourself into something
that you know you don't follow through
on and it's in a work way worse than if
they had had the sense to say no no
too hot we won't touch it you know then
they would have been left alone but once
you take it on then you have to own it
and they didn't own it
so now they're all gone
Lloyd old
and Bob good and Louis Thomas they all
died of cancer
so you know it's quite ironic
you know while they were while they were
fighting over this this treatment they
also were incubating the tumors that
well the conditions that killed them